Josh Brolin has been a formidable
presence in Hollywood since he was a
teen but these days his body is getting
as much attention as his body of work
the acclaimed actor has packed on a ton
of muscle for an upcoming
larger-than-life role here's how josh
brolin got so massively jacked for his
role as cable and Deadpool to comically
large Brolin's ascension to swoln Espino
page with the actor taking a few
drawings of cable to one of his personal
trainers to get specific about what he
wanted but here's the thing
cables most well-known look was put
together by Rob Liefeld an artist whose
work is frequently defined by insanely
pumped up stylized and unrealistic body
shapes
Justin Lovato a personal trainer and
body builder who worked with Brolin on
his look said to get even halfway close
to the insanely huge upper body cable
has in the comics Brolin spent 3 hours a
day in the gym for 6 weeks straight
killing the carbs Brolin had to wean
himself off of carbohydrates to get cut
like cable and he wasn't happy about it
at first in one of many of his
inspirational Instagram posts Brolin
laid it all out cables coming growing
from the inside clean building from a
past of donut travel to the present hard
case that he is no sugar no bread no
pastas the machine is being built I'm
pissed off in another poster recording
of an upper-body workout he shared his
pride in going totally clean no drugs
none of it fish rice eggs veggies water
I'm almost 50 it's a different time our
access along with some big-picture
discipline results in always surprising
milestones get on the train cheap day to
transform into cable Brolin says it
required intense mental focus to stay in
a fit frame of mind but it's also ok to
have a cheat day as long as it benefits
that mindset this challenge has been an
awakening that there is no excuse ever
but there's no need for perfection cheat
days replenish and tell your body it's
ok it keeps it from panicking which
usually shuts it down and ends up giving
you a worse result keep at it then when
the day comes murder that friggin donut
support network of course no one gets
movie star buff without a little
professional help in Brolin acknowledged
that the progress he made with his body
is the result of a team effort writing
it takes a small village in an Instagram
post tipping his hat to his trainer and
of course he always has a shout-out for
Catherine Brolin his wife
business partner and frequently the eye
behind the camera for his fitness clips
on social media the actor also finds
encouragement through fellow members of
the thespian League of muscleheads
performers like professional wrestler
turned actor Dave Bautista a man Brolin
calls his great swole mentor Brolin also
related a delightful encounter he had
with the man who plays Drax the
destroyer in a post on Instagram just
saw Dave Bautista at the gym and he said
what the Cap'n to you haha best
compliment ever friendly competition
while positive encouragement is always
nice having a rival can be beneficial as
well encouraging the spirit of
competition Brolin has gotten plenty of
that motivation from Deadpool to co-star
Ryan Reynolds who tag social media
photos of cable hashtag premium cable
and hash tag maximum for his part Brolin
is more than capable of firing back on
Instagram he shared a photo of the two
stars side-by-side on competing magazine
covers Ryan Reynolds smartass secrets or
Josh Brolin's beating his demons to
become Hollywood's go-to Hellraiser it's
just not fair on brand along with his
wife Catherine the actor recently
launched an active wear clothing line
Preval which he promotes in his workout
posts infrequently sports it's not just
for his own bottom line either the
limited edition cable swoll line of
t-shirts tank tops and hoodies benefits
organizations like the st. Jude's
Children's Research Hospital so in
addition to keeping him healthy getting
swole for Deadpool 2 has also helped the
49 year old raise money for charity and
promote the family business double duty
Brolin is not only getting ripped to
play cable
he's also staying fit to once again play
Thanos in Avengers infinity war yes
Thanos is largely CGI and makeup but the
Wizards at Marvel will also be putting
as much of Roland's physical performance
on screen as they can through the
process of motion capture fortunately
Brolin's done the hard work and the
whole world will get to see the fruits
of his labor when the one-two punch of a
New Avengers movie and Deadpool to hit
cinemas in 2018 thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
you